jetzt ist hier oben auf dem wohnwagen
drauf was jetzt die mission statt
nein einfach nein einfach nein jetzt
kommt sondern die leute heute mit einer
zuschauer einsendung zwar die liebe
marie mir auf installieren beschrieben
und mich gebeten dass ich mal auf ein
ganz spezielles video reagiere dem komme
ich natürlich gerne in dem heutigen
video nach leute das geht soweit video
von sahne dani mit dem video titel den
bullischen tag der abrechnung aller die
wissen was ist mit dani und saale und
allem auch sie hat die wissen was dort
auf uns zukommt das ist
ich sage nur so viel war daher gerade
dieses ganze konzept mit sahne ist mein
leben ist so geistig hängen geblieben
aber schauen wir ein schutz habe ich
auch keinen mehr
wenn ich diese frau in jersey kriege ich
schon wieder trauben arbeiter leute ich
habe schon mal ich hab ein oder zwei
videos maximal zwei glaube ich habe ich
schon mal zu dani gemacht jedes einzelne
dieser videos hat mich persönlich an
meine grenzen der psychischen
belastbarkeit gebracht immer gesagt
gespannt wie dieses video verläuft ich
will ganz kurz auf zwei sachen loswerden
heute erstmals zu dem letzten video von
vor zwei tagen das war direkt schon zu
ich sehe von katja das video hier
herunter genommen weil das feedback von
euch so wat dass ihr fallen dass meine
götter zu weit gegangen sind und dass
wir euch deswegen ich gefallen hat wenn
ich natürlich dann auch okay mit sowie
das müsst ihr euch gefallen wenn sie es
nicht tun dann nämlich wieder runter und
die zweite sache leute wenn ihr weitere
videos für mich zu reagieren hat könnte
die genau wie marie gerne auf install
desktop schicken dann bekommt ihr auch
und schaut hier in dem video wenn ein
staat angenommen wird und jetzt weiter
ich brauche schutz kreis
wer das konzept für diese sendung für
diese einzelnen drews schreibt muss
wirklich einen preis bekommt für die
abgefahrensten vorstellungen die ein
mensch überhaupt haben kann dort allein
schon das grundkonzept von dieser serie
bei family stories bei dani ist ja dass
sie süchtig nach sahne ist es gibt so
viele auf der welt warum sahne und zu
allem überfluss glaubt die auch noch an
so zauberei und so was sehen wir jetzt
gerade im schusskreis das also schutz
kreisky schützt uns denke ich mal vor
irgendwelchen bösen mächten oder so die
leute wenn man wenn man schon erzählt
dass man an so etwas glaubt anschutz
kreise und ein was weiß ich welche
gespenster oder sofort dem man sich
schützen muss dann mach es doch
wenigstens ordentlich alter sie schmeißt
wirklich einfach nur steine ja gerade
durch die gegend decker welchen dämonen
soll das abhalten
vielleicht irgendein arbeitslosen timo
aber nicht
warum alles so muss ich hier irgendwo
auf diesem boden waagerecht gibt wochen
[Musik]
war das zählt zur wieder dicker ich hab'
ich habe wirklich keinerlei beck sowie
zu diesem video ich habe es einfach von
der ihnen zugesandt bekommen schauen wir
dass wir an ich weiß dass es diese sagen
dann ist das die becks aviso ist dass
sie wieder da ist kann sich aber was hat
diese tür jetzt gerade getan
warum ist hier war mal so sauer man muss
sich ja irgendwie auf diesem boden wagen
klettern
ich habe dann überall versuchter
hochzuklettern links rechts vorne dran
hinten dran und um einen schutz kreis
dann zu segnen bin ich zu der mentalen
überzeugung gelangt ich habe da auch
nochmal mit den dämonen die in der nähe
waren gesprochen und uns verständigt
dass ich jetzt erst mal das rücklicht
wirklich einfach dass unschuldige
rückweg von meinem wohnwagen abtreten
muss es ist mir egal was hat das mit
dämonen abwehr oder geister abwehr oder
irgendwas zu tun
dass das schlimmste hier das ist
wirklich dass das eine fernsehproduktion
ist irgendwo da draußen in deutschland
ja und ich will dass diese personen sich
jetzt angesprochen fühlt hat sich ein
kamera team zusammengefunden und haben
einfach das gedreht mit dem bewusstsein
dass das ins fernsehen kommt ins
fernsehen wohl nur geprüfte beiträge
reinkommt wisst ihr im fernsehen ist ja
nicht so dass man ihm das abfilmen und
das dann einfach durch darf nein das
habe nix leute abgesegnet haben diesen
videobeitrag gesehen und gesagt ja dass
das gutes wollen wir senden wie jetzt
hier oben auf dem wohnwagen drauf was
jetzt
das ist wirklich das ist wirklich das
krasseste wenn ich hier bei der decke
und das heftigste und absurdeste dass
irgendjemand das abgesegnet hat das kann
kann wirklich nicht wahr sein das kann
nicht sein ich will ich will dass diese
leute zur verantwortung gezogen werden
leute dass das geht mich das geht
überhaupt nichts steinkreis du bist nun
gesegnet
der steiger sitz gesichert
nächste frage kommt sie da wieder runter
oder bleibt jetzt einmal da oben immer
vor was nur das tor das wäre steht auf
dem grabstein so ja dani ist auf den
wohnwagen hoch geklettert um den
steinkreis zu segnen
ich hätte ja nicht mal wieder runter
gekommen ok hat das ganze drama geht
jetzt weiter jetzt ist daniel auf der
suche nach einer toilette und das ganze
gestaltet sich so sie ist da schauen
beim schrank trainierte wie wir uns
nicht mal wie du ja wie soll man eine
funktionierende gehirn zeit hatte man
schon dieses videos übrig haben wie sich
jetzt also ich sage ich bin kein camping
profi aber man setzt sich doch nicht in
den strassengraben auch dieses ding das
nimmt man doch raus und stellte sowohl
den wald auf dem boden oder so oder oder
es ist ein fucking kleiderschrank als ob
man sich in den schrank rhein setzt nach
ich gesehen
da musste ich sowieso stolz ist raus das
ist wirklich so aggressiver schmutz
alter wisst ihr wisst ihr was mir machen
wird ich will einerseits will ich die
leute die das hier drehen und
verantworten zur verantwortung ziehen
aber andererseits ich will mal stellt
euch nach vorne ist reiner to love
challenge mit dem kameramann oder den
kameramännern oder frauen die dieses
video hier drehen und allgemein solche
at/tv sachen ich sag euch leute diese
menschen die könnt ihr nicht zum lachen
bringen die haben alles schon gesehen
was ist das
[Musik]
ihr könnt einfach drauf wetten da sind
bestimmt keine also ich schätze mal
mindestens mindestens drei leute die das
hauptberuflich machen fernsehen machen
ja sachen produzieren sind hier und
drehen das mit wahrscheinlich sogar noch
mehr wahrscheinlich also 5 bis 10
was ist das ist mir diese leute nach
hause kommen so fakt oder der freund
oder die freundin sonja die war der
heutige arbeitszeit so die person also
ja ja ich habe so eine etwas kräftigere
frau dabei gefilmt wie sie in wohnwagen
kaputt macht und sich seine in dem und
spritzwasser leidiger was ein arbeitstag
klicke dich ja was hat dieser wohnwagen
getan ich habe mir noch eine tür
ja ich würde davor hattest du einen
wohnwagen der relativ gut funktioniert
hat ganz wahr indem man übernachten kann
und eine tür
jetzt hast du einfach in kaputten
wohnwagen einen haufen schrott und zwei
türen
da muss persönlich ganz klar sagen
option 2 ist natürlich die bessere okay
jetzt schicke ich auch warum sie diesen
wohnwagen kaputt machen leute
sie macht diesen wohnwagen einfach
kaputt weil sie auf der suche nach sahne
ist logischerweise wie die meisten von
uns auch reagieren würden wenn wir die
sahne nicht finden wird neben alles um
uns herum auseinander ist ja klar
also ich habe jetzt einen nennenswerten
teil von diesem video angeschaut wollte
und ich muss wirklich sagen meinen
standpunkt bleibt ich finde wirklich
ernsthaft dass sowas sollte sollte es
nicht geben das sollte bin ich existiere
ja das ist so asozial wer guckt es den
anderen zieht da irgendwas für sich raus
aus seinem leben aber schreibt mir dass
man die kommentare leute jetzt wirklich
auf ernst findet ihr sowas sollte im
fernsehen überhaupt laufen ich
persönlich finde mich aber erst einmal
dass wir die kommentare ab hier einfach
vorstellen kann kann ich will an der
stelle wirklich wirklich heraus